your idea may be original but it's more
likely that your idea is similar to ones
that have come before it to further
validate your idea and to determine if
your product is differentiated you
should look at competitors first you'll
need to know who your competitors are
you can quickly find the competition by
searching for keywords related to your
product idea you want to make sure that
you use words that customers would use
to describe your product or something
similar seems like we have a couple
competitors in the news already at least
for the grocery shopping app idea once
you've done that you can collect some
basic info on the companies using Whois
net Facebook and Twitter creation dates
for companies are listed on all three
sites but do keep in mind that
businesses could have started even
sooner on the Whois net the information
is just below the fold
here's the information for instacart you
can find more information on your
competitors by going to websites such as
similarweb and SEM rush you can either
search for web sites or mobile apps on
the results page you can get a sense for
how the app is doing the traffic sources
and keywords that people use to search
for the app now if we switch this over
to the website it will look a little bit
different here you can get a sense of
the traffic overview the geography of
the traffic referring websites search
keywords including organic and paid and
social referrals from different web
sites other items you may be consider
looking into include the competitors
social media interactions what are they
writing about and how our customers
talking about the brand or the product
if you're iterating on your product or
trying to understand other companies
value propositions then I encourage you
to look at their own home pages and
landing pages for specific products